zach thompson his 13th start of this
season and of his career a solid outing
against this very same reds teams
and he gets to india in the first a
strikeout one and two
on tyler naquin
gets into that ball a bash to deep right
jesus sanchez
can't get there home run
16 straight games with a naked base hit
and this one clears the fence one
nothing reds yeah i think wade's gonna
have a little chip on his shoulder he
obviously was a little frustrated his
last time out
and there's another swing in this first
k for miley two down alfaro swings and
skies the fly ball to shallow right
castianos moves under it he's got it
side retired the marlins are done
quietly in the first a walk and one left
fly ball out to right started back comes
in sanchez makes the play three fly ball
outs for zach thompson in a one two
three second
and that is a line drive base hit into
center field and they get four games in
a row with a hit for brian anderson who
is aboard to lead things off here in the
second
runner off a little late india snap
shovel farmer relay in time
nicely done
double play
broken bad soft roller to farmer to his
left gloves near second throws in time
and de la cruz is out well that does it
the marlins go quietly after a leadoff
single in the second
on 1-1 miley pulls on the ground
aguilard first base has it over near the
line takes him to the bag himself one
out
now the fastball up that is last just
fair opposite way down the line naked
storms up to second base and it's
another extra base hit tyler naked with
two for two played tyler naked at second
with
two outs
and perfect timing this one is skyed
to shortstop it's going to be miggy if
it ever comes down
makes the play and thompson strands a
rudder
and so why wouldn't the pitcher get a
hit paul there you go this might be
extra bases here goes thompson chugging
into second take that batting average
against here comes jazz with the runner
on second and two outs in the third
as chisholm that'll be a race to the bag
by bottom and chisholm and botto
will take it himself a double in the
inning but he will be stranded out there
breaking ball that he bops into the gap
that's going to skip and elude alfaro
all the way to the wall
standing double for joey votto when
mustaches is on time with a pitch
boy it seems like he's just got a really
beautiful swing
mustache
that's going to get over
sanchez windmill on bravado
he rips it home bustaka slides into
second poll free safe mike mustakis legs
out the double some loose calls in south
florida and a two nothing reds lead they
will face wade miley now miley hits
pretty well as a pitcher
and wade miley says take that pictures
rake
mustache scores truck to third
wade miley to second base
rp high double
grounds it sharply to the backhand of
the shortstop rojas he gloves high throw
and he sails it over aguilar into the
camera well it's out of play india will
be given second the reds will get two
runs
and the reds now lead it five to nothing
and that's there for strike three
aguilar does not agree wade miley paints
the edge
alfaro has been very consistent of lake
right
very active in the upper half
i'm gonna try and get a hustle double
and he does
never slowed down
swing and a miss
second k of the inning third of the
night for wade miley
strike three call got him looking
fastball to sanchez over the inside
corner he is down on strikes wade miley
punches out three
feels like miley's picking up even more
momentum as this game wears on
a 1-1 there's a little line drive chest
high caught by farmer it's short and the
inning is over but a two out single from
sandy leone all the marlins have doing
here in the fifth inning
bouncer to second that's jazz
and we will head to the last of the six
another start another dynamite
performance so far for wade miley
there's a ground ball headed for third
right at mustache who was drawn in he
throws in time to get jazz chisholm
there's one out in the sixth
there's a base hit for aguilar
[Applause]
a one out knock
strike three cold
anderson shakes his head
miley
rolling
lots of family and friends
here today for jonathan india his dad on
hand castiano's
ground ball to anderson
to jazz and on to first it's a double
play orleans go around the horn and it's
the seventh inning stretch hello deep
wade miley
as it will be picked off on the fly by
tyler and aquin coming in the shallow
right center field
bottom
wade miley
automatic
he goes seven scoreless here's mike
mustakis with nobody on and one man out
mike
a towering bomb
the moose calls echo
as he launches a huge homer to right
field a six nothing reds lead and home
with the 01 pitch breaking ball grounded
to short should be two farmer to india
around to first in time that is a 6-4-3
double play
sofaro chops a high one hopper to the
third baseman mustaches he comes in
gloves throws low but vato stretches and
digs it out to make the play at first
the inning is over
swing and a miss hoffman strikes out de
la cruz a one two three nine
and the reds begin their series in miami
with shutout success they blank the fish
six to nothing